There're four people and two on each team.
You have to get the letter L and O...
There's skipping, swimming, running...
...and one art picture.
You need to wear protective gloves and a helmet.
First, they get up in a line.
Start off with a ball, and they throw it behind them.
You have to look at the ball the whole time...
...cause you don't know if it's going to turn into a Frisbee, a football,...
...a horseshoe, you don't know what it's going to turn into.
You have a penalty!
For what?
Throw it to their partner.
It would change and then you'll have to catch it.
I like the red team.
I like the blue team.
When it's in the middle, you have to get your tennis thingy.
You have to go all the way round.
Don't let people...
I didn't do anything!
And they throw it to their partner but their partner just sits down.
If anyone says stop, then the person who has the ball will have to put it...
...with the tennis thingy without using their hands.
You have to catch it and if you don't catch it, you have to go in the jail.
He grabs it and scores.
And if he doesn't score, he's kicked out of the team.
And once you get a point you get to say, "I got a rainbow!"